we lived in Austin almost eight years
people think of it being sort of
isolated but it's really not you're
pretty connected between the public
transportation and streets highways etc
to the rest of the city it's it's kind
of a nice little area to be it feels
safe it feels very neighborhood oriented
it's very eclectic which is a great
thing for kids when you look at your
population and you can say that was over
a third of your population you know I
speakers of other languages it brings
newness and it brings prints a sense of
coming together cooperation and sharing
in order to to move or to to be
something would be some where you've got
people who've lived here for generations
of people who have moved here or
recently like us but everybody melds
together pretty well the thing that's
really missing from this neighborhood
you know in Austin is the fact that
there aren't a lot of cultural offerings
I think the opening of the new ed portal
it's kind of an exciting prospect and a
dimension that's going to widen the
perspective of people who who want to be
lifelong learners this can be you know
an exciting place to twenty-four Western
Ave becomes an address that everybody
knows I'd like to see that
this is where the emerging Harvard
campus meets the Austin neighborhood
what is the harbor today a Harvard is to
every single kid not able an opportunity
financial growth and it's a place where
the same spirit of discovery and
partnership that inspires students and
faculty in our classrooms can enliven
activities here it truly is that give
people opportunities to get a chance to
get a flavor what happens in Harvard but
it's the collaboration between Harvard
and city of Boston that's really what
this is ultimately all about to advance
people advance communities and do a lot
of good positive things
we believe that learning is a journey
across your entire life we are now in a
world where knowledge is not just static
people don't do one thing on the time
they start their their careers until the
very end and the Harvard ed portal is a
place we are no matter where you are in
that journey you can actually learn here
what's fantastic about the Harvard ed
portal being at its heart situated in
Austin is an Austin really represents
that closest neighbor partner community
that we have already built a bridge to
that we can really work with to
experiment to create new models that
ultimately will have a wider effect in
Boston but it really starts with also it
provides people like me who are grad
students the chance to actually interact
day-to-day with Boston Public Schools
and the family and the community
organizations that are here in Austin
and Brighton I see this as becoming you
know like a focus point in the Austin
Brighton area I look a lot of our our
mothers and just the different things
that could be offered to them literacy
programs health literacy using some of
their department in their professors to
come and to talk to people and what does
that do to build up their confidence
that says you know I'm doing this at the
Harvard portal the notion of learning
without limits focuses on the idea that
no one is boxed in by the previous
background or even by what they think
they're capable of doing learning is a
process where ultimately you can open
any door and so the Harvard ed portal is
really designed to open as many doors
for as many people as possible
I'm just doing video